[Musique]
devant l'impossibilité de renouveler ses
concerts avec public l'association pour
la promotion de la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines à trouver une
solution au lieu d'accueillir près de
4000 enfants des écoles de
l'agglomération
elle a enregistré le concert en vidéo
les 25 et 26 mars dernier cette année le
kobe nous interdit d'avoir les enfants
et les personnes dans la salle donc on
fait l' inverse cirque on va amener
l'orchestré dans les familles et dans
les écoles qu'on pourrait dire avec un
peu d'humour que avant le faisaient
plutôt façon théâtre et là on le fait
plutôt façon cinéma
objectif faire découvrir la musique
classique dès le plus jeune âge à des
élèves qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité d'en écouter et pour peut
être aussi susciter des vocations
la barrière qui empêche les enfants de
faire de la musique classique on pense
qu'elle est financière et n'est pas
financière et la culture elle est donc
c'est tout l'objet de la paix mais ce qu
de porter la culture dans les milieux où
elle a de la peine à arriver
une quarantaine de musiciens de
l'ensemble instrumental de lavilledieu
étaient donc présents pour cette
captation vidéo au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au
conservatoire de trappes cette année ils
ont joué le concerto pour piano d'edvard
grieg un grand compositeur norvégien
déjà la partie de piano et très théâtral
comme vous verrez très virtuose l'
orchestre est un orchestre au grand
complet avec des vents des bois des
cuivres percussions cordes et c'est une
oeuvre qui s'enracine dans les mélodies
populaires et molly populaire parle aux
enfants
la vidéo du concert sera mise en ligne
prochainement sur le site internet de la
paix m excuse
l'association va également contacté les
enseignants de saint quentin en yvelines
pour la diffuser au maximum auprès des
plus jeunes
[Musique]